une question de passion nature pêche et
ce n'est pas la première qu'il ou elle
nous pose pourquoi biteau heureux comme
un poisson dans l'eau franchement avoué
que dire heureux comme un poisson sur
terre n'aurait pas beaucoup de sens en
fait l'origine de cette expression
remonterait au xiiie siècle à l'époque
on disait volontiers être sain comme un
poisson dans l'eau ou à la rivière
l'expression or et évoluer dans le
courant du xviie siècle pour prendre la
forme qu'on lui connaît aujourd'hui
heureux comme un poisson dans l'eau elle
signifie tout simplement qu'une personne
est aussi à l'aise dans un domaine ou
dans un lieu que peut l'être un poisson
dans son milieu naturel l'eau douce et
l'eau salée et c'est exactement ce que
je ressens en ce moment même quand je
réponds à vos questions